Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Ausgabe Nummer siebenunddreißig. Äh mein Name ist Tim Brittlav und das hier ist natürlich, wie sollte es anders sein? Ein Corona Weekly,
Und ich griff irgendwie in ein Regal heute und hatte so eine leere Bierflasche auf einmal in der Hand. Wusste gar nicht warum und dann guckte ich drauf und stand drauf,
Corona extra. Sind so die die Dinge, die man heutzutage so ein bisschen beiseite legt und ich dachte mir, da wir gar nicht mehr so Weekleys sind, wäre vielleicht Corona extra fast den besseren Name gewesen für diesen Podcast. So oder so bin ich wieder zusammen mit,
Pavel am Start. Hallo Pavel. Gefällt dir das? Corona extra.
Ja, doch äh hat was, hat was.
Hätte den Vorteil, dass wir uns da nicht so festlegen, was so den Veröffentlichungszyklus betrifft, obwohl so wie es derzeit aussieht, steuern wir ohnehin bald wieder auf Weekleed zu.
Würde halt immer äh funktionieren. Eure Gelegenheit in den Kommentaren äh für Stimmungsbilder zu sorgen.
Ja, vielleicht fangen wir damit auch mal äh an. Ähm.
Ja, heute ist der erste zehnte. Äh vielleicht noch äh vorne wegzuschicken.
Jawoll,
sehr guter Hinweis. Der erste zehnte zwanzig zwanzig. Ähm ich würde mal sagen, allgemeiner Zustand, so für die Leute, die den Podcast fünfhundert Jahre später nachhören. Ähm in Deutschland macht sich noch keine Panik breit.
Oder? Kann man so sagen.
Ja, ne, besonders panisch äh sieht das alles nicht aus. Da gebe ich dir Recht. Ja.
Also ich habe so dieses Gefühl, man hat sich jetzt so im Wesentlichen mit dem ganzen Unbild den das so mit sich gebracht hat, abgefunden.
Klar gibt natürlich immer noch so ein paar äh Leute, die der Meinung sind, da ein großes Fass draus machen zu müssen, wobei die es irgendwie auch.
Weiß ich nicht, habe ich irgendwas verpasst oder hat sich das irgendwie ein bisschen gelegt gerade? Ich weiß es nicht.
Was gelegt.
Na ja, die ganzen Schreihälse, die ganze Zeit irgendwelche, die Welt geht unter äh Demos machen müssen, weil sie irgendwie ein Stück Stoff sich auf die Nase legen sollen.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass da weniger Geschrei äh ist, sondern die mediale Aufmerksamkeit, der mediale Aufmerksamkeitsscheinwerfer äh ist nicht mehr da. Äh.
Diese Gruppen so gerichtet, weil das,
egal was, es kann halt immer nur eine begrenzte Zeit in den Medien bleiben, interessiert seit keinen,
Aber ja ich habe schon, also ich höre schon äh auch so aus den Medien nach wie vor so ein leichtes Rumoren äh hm,
so also die die Stimmen, die sagen, das ist alles überzogen und übertrieben sind nicht verstummt.
Und ja aber medial nicht mehr so präsent, würde ich, so würde ich das einschätzen.
Also mir tut das auf jeden Fall ganz gut. Dass da nicht so viel drüber berichtet wird. Ich meine
gibt so viele Dinge, über die man wahrscheinlich stattdessen berichten sollte und vielleicht findet das ja auch gerade statt. Ich würde mir nicht zu viel Hoffnung machen natürlich was so die Auswahl, die Themenauswahl der Medien betrifft, aber na ja, so ist es schon irgendwie ganz okay,
Ja, dann äh hatten wir irgendwie so eine Stille. Äh letztes Mal.
Wo du sagtest, wäre mal toll, wenn's mal so einen Film gäbe, der mal so schön äh erklärt, wie denn das mit dem Immunsystem so funktioniert. Und ich hatte das dann schon irgendwie auf der Zunge, aber mir fiel's in dem Moment nicht ein,
Natürlich kann man's dann gleich in den Kommentaren, dass es sowas schon äh äh gibt, schon sehr lange gibt, nämlich äh diese Zeichentrickserie. Es war einmal das Leben.
Aus Frankreich sechsundachtzig kam das glaube ich raus, wo so in mehreren Folgen so einmal quer,
durch das Leben durchgegangen wurde, unter anderem eben auch eine Folge zum Immunsystem,
die werden wir dann mal verlinken. Das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht ganz der Detailgrad und sicherlich auch noch nicht der Stand der Medizin, den wir jetzt unbedingt, den du jetzt gerne abbilden möchtest, aber ähm.
Zumindest nicht so, dass da jetzt doch keiner auf die Idee gekommen wäre.
Er, er, er, ja, aber ich, aber es hat sich Tage habe ich in den letzten dreißig Jahren so richtig äh viel getan nochmal.
Absolut, klar.
Das ist so der Hauptpunkt, aber ich muss, werd's mir unbedingt auch mal anschauen.
Mindestens im Vergleich, ich meine, das ist natürlich äh im Prinzip sechsundachtzig heißt, dass es so Prämoderne Gentechnik,
Also diese ganze Entschlüsselung des Genoms und äh natürlich auch die Möglichkeiten da ähm interessant einzugreifen.
Um halt auch neue Testens äh Kenntnisse zu machen, dass halt alles später gekommen und von daher.
Ja, es ist mehr so ein Ding, was man mal neu machen müsste vielleicht auf eine andere Art und Weise und vielleicht schon etwas bitte ein bisschen breiteres äh Publikum. Das hat sich dann doch eher an Kinder gewendet. Nichtsdestotrotz interessant.
Ja
haben wir noch ähm was Wichtiges aufzugreifen nur Sachen, auf die wir später noch kommen werden. Von daher würde ich sagen, machen wir erstmal ganz traditionell unseren Blick,
auf die Zahlen, du hast ja wahrscheinlich wieder ordentlich zusammengefegt mit deinem mit deiner Datenbank.
Was was lesen wir, was Glaskugeln wir aus dem Zahlenwerk.
Ja, also seit
fünf Wochen ähm so ziehen die Zahlen bundesweit äh weiter an, beziehungsweise von den Zahlen rede, dann äh beziehe ich mich hauptsächlich immer
auf die äh
Infektionen der letzten sieben Tage oder genauer gesagt die positiven Tests der letzten sieben Tage äh so manche Leute werden ja auch mehrfach getestet, aber das
ist halt auch eher nur proportional, aber auf jeden Fall ja,
sind wir jetzt,
fahren wir immer wieder neue Rekorde ein, auch bei Tagesrekorden, also seit Aprilrekorde muss man äh dazu sagen und äh sind,
aber auch längst noch nicht dort, wo wir auf dem Höhepunkt waren.
Äh jetzt selbst nach nach reinen äh Zahlen, aber äh ja, die Zahlen steigen, das R,
ist zwischen eins und.
Eins Komma zwei schwankt dazwischen im Moment irgendwo zwischen in der Nähe bei eins Komma eins etwas unter eins Komma eins. Das heißt, wir haben zwar irgendwie eigentlich einen exponentiellen,
Anstieg seit zwei Wochen aber mit einem sehr kleinen Exponenten. So das heißt eigentlich sieht die Kurve eher linear,
aus, aber sie, die steigt und wahrscheinlich ja wie gesagt, wir haben
so wahrscheinlich zwei bis vier Monate Zeit ungefähr bis es hier richtig ungemütlich wird. So, aber es sieht im Moment.
Auch so aus, als wenn es dann in zwei bis vier Monaten ungemütlich werden wird, obwohl natürlich eine Vorhersage gerade,
praktisch kaum möglich ist, selbst wenn man sich mal den RKI Now Cast äh anschaut, gibt es da keinen klaren Hinweis äh in einer Woche können die Zahlen rauf oder runter äh gehen, da deutet sich
auch nicht wirklich einen Trend an.
Zwei bis vier Monate saß er.
Zwei bis vier Monate bis wir dann auch bis wir dann auf einem Level sind, wo ja es ist wirklich.
Unerträglich wird, sagen wir mal so.
Also Weihnachten wird's ungemütlich, sagst du.
Um Weihnachten rum, also sieht alles so aus, dass das um Weihnachten rum so genau die Zeit erreicht wird, wo einfach.
Super. Das heißt, Weihnachten soll man an seine Großeltern äh nicht mehr besuchen. Die werden sich ja freuen. Das äh das könnte ja, das könnte dann schon wieder zu Verwerfungen führen.
Ja, leider zeigt sich auch jetzt so in den letzten sieben Tagen
sind auch die Sterbezahlen leider erstmalig seit längerem angezogen und sind jetzt auch wieder ja auf Juni Niveau,
an angestiegen. Äh also seit seit Juni äh gab es äh keine.
Woche oder kein Sieben-Tageszeitraum, wo so viele Menschen gestorben sind, wie.
Ende Juni muss man dazu sagen, ne? Also im Juni ist es ja die Zahlen der enorm abgesunken und so der Ende Juni stand, dann ist es im
Juli nochmal besser geworden und seitdem Mian hat so die Todesrate so ein bisschen hoch, um ein bisschen runter. Und was du jetzt berichtest, würde ich sagen, ist so der
erste kleine, vorsichtige Ausreißer über so diese Mittelschwankungen der letzten drei Monate ungefähr,
also noch nicht total beunruhigend, aber zumindest schon mal so sichtbar und vor allem wirkt es.
Das ist das erste Mal so, als ob die Zahl der neu infizierten und die Zahl der Toten überhaupt noch in irgendeiner Korrelation steht.
Ne, weil weil weil das einfach so lange gedauert hat, ne. Wir beobachten ja jetzt im Prinzip,
mehr oder weniger durchgehenden Anstieg der Zahl seit Mitte Juli.
Und eben bis jetzt hat's gedauert, bis sich das in irgendeiner Form äh bei den Todeszahlen.
Zu erkennen gibt und wir haben ja nun auch schon mehrfach gerätselt woran das liegen kann. Gibt ja auch zahlreiche äh Gründe, aber es kann im Wesentlichen vor allem damit zu tun haben, dass einfach die Infektionszahlen ähm.
Ja, nicht so hoch waren, dass sich das sofort äh gezeigt hätte.
Bringt uns, falls du nicht noch was anderes sagen wolltest, weil ich wollte mal dieses Mysterium dieser ersten Welle nochmal so ein bisschen äh aufschlagen, wenn man sich jetzt diesen Zahlenverlauf anschaut.
Also nochmal, wir hatten so eine erste Welle, die Infektionszahlen schossen hoch. Dann.
Gab's diese Maßnahmen, die drei aufeinanderfolgenden, großen äh Schritte, also Unterbindung von Veranstaltungen, Kontaktverbot et cetera, das haben wir ja alles schon mal
besprochen gehabt, dass das eben auch nachhaltig Wirkung gezeigt hat
Weil danach ging halt diese Infektionszahlen nach unten, dann rauschte sie in den Keller, alle waren irgendwie happy, der Sommer äh fing an. Dann gab's irgendwie so ein kleine erste Tönes äh Hopser so, also verschiedene große Ausbruchsfälle an einzelnen Orten, die so
Die Statistik ein wenig durcheinander gebracht haben, das hat sich dann auch wieder ein bisschen gefangen und jetzt eben seit Anfang August diese kontinuierliche,
Anstieg zu dem Punkt, wo wir eben jetzt sind. Dem gegenüber stehen dann halt die Todeszahlen
am Anfang auch heftig waren, was ja dann auch dazu geführt hat, dass man gesehen hat, so okay, alles klar, hier sterben auf einmal sehr viele Leute in Deutschland. Ähm das ist schon recht gefährlich,
Wenn man aber jetzt mal den Verlauf der Kurve jetzt, also der,
Kurve der Gestorbenen im Verhältnis zu den infizierten ähm Vergleich zu, wie das in der ersten Welle gelaufen ist, ist halt diese.
Todesrate an den infizierten sehr viel näher dran. Was uns ja auch immer dieses diesen Blick gegeben hat mit.
Das ist eine sehr gefährliche Krankheit. Was der Zweifelsohne ist und wenn ihr nicht so viele Leute dran gestorben, nur die Frage war ja immer ähm jetzt muss ich äh aufpassen, dass ich nicht den falschen Begriff äh benutze, was die.
Mortalität.
Äh oh Gott, das war jetzt bestimmt, oder ist das die Letalität? Habe ich jetzt nicht mehr so ganz äh präsent. Ich formuliere es mal anders. Also inwiefern sich Infektionszahlen eben dann letzten Endes wirklich auch in äh Tode,
tote Leute äh übersetzen lässt. In welchem Verhältnis das steht und wenn ich mir jetzt so diese Kurve so anschaue, habe ich so ein bisschen so den Eindruck.
Diese erste Welle, die wir da gemessen haben und für die wir Zahlen generiert haben durch diese Testereien im März und im April.
Müsse eigentlich viel, viel, viel, viel, viel größer noch gewesen sein, als wir sie aufgeschrieben haben.
Ja. Also ich würde davon ausgehen, dass im, dass im März und Anfang
April beziehungsweise hauptsächlich aber ja eigentlich im März so die Dunkelziffer äh wahrscheinlich zehn bis zwanzig Mal,
so hoch war, äh wie sie äh aktuell
ist so, das heißt, dass ihr eigentlich damals die Fallzahlen nochmal mit zehn oder zwanzig hätten multiplizieren müssen. Wobei
da auch noch der Effekt dann kam, dass die Tests natürlich auch massiv ausgeweitet wurden
aber man kann auch dann äh sehen, dass so in der Kalenderwoche vierzehn, das ist ja Ende März Anfang,
April ähm hatten wir eine hm,
positiven Quote bei den bei den Tests von, ich glaube neun Prozent und jetzt liegen wir bei um die ein Prozent, das heißt auch alle von.
Den Leuten, die getestet wurden, waren fast äh zehn Mal äh so viele äh positiv, wie aktuell, wobei gutes Testregime hat sich auch geändert. Wir testen,
jetzt auch Leute, die äh keine Symptome haben. Das war
damals noch nicht so, weil's einfach die Tests auch noch nicht verfügbar waren und selbst wenn du jemanden im Haushalt hattest, äh so und du selber keine Symptome gezeigt hast, hättest du damals noch ein Problem irgendwie einen Test
zu kriegen eigentlich und das ist jetzt nicht mehr so ja ähm.
Also gewisser Hinsicht finde ich das ja eine beruhigende Nachricht.
Wenn man das jetzt mal so drauf schaut ja und vielleicht sollte man an dieser Stelle nochmal kurz erwähnen, also wir sind äh.
Weder äh Statistiker noch ähm.
Virologen noch sonst eigentlich irgendwas, auf Twitter hat sich auch schon einer äh beschwert äh warum sich denn jetzt bitte äh auf einmal Informatiker an solche,
Interpretationen wagen, ja, so auf uns bezogen, wo ich dann sagte, naja, wir sind noch nicht mal Informatiker.
Es ist noch viel schlimmer, ja?
Nee, wir sind einfach nur so, da äh zwei daher gelaufene Dudes äh die zu viel Zeit haben und äh sich das gerne regelmäßig anschauen, um irgendwie ihre eigenen Schlüsse zu ziehen.
Und ihr könnt es sozusagen jetzt einfach so nehmen wie wir es sagen, aber ihr müsst den ordentlich viel Bedeutung beim Essen. Nur.
Viele Zahlen legen natürlich äh auch Dinge nahe. Und es hält auch nicht so, dass wir jetzt immer komplett daneben gelegen hätten.
Warum ich sage, das ist beruhigend.
Man muss wohl davon ausgehen, dass halt im Februar, März, kurz nachdem halt in Italien das so richtig losging, es eigentlich auch in Deutschland schon richtig losging.
Und es ist ja auch nicht sonderlich überraschend. Diese Länder sind nahe beieinander. Der ganze äh Skiurlaub und Tirolurlaub und so weiter. Also zu glauben, die Alpen werden da jetzt irgendwie nennenswerter Schutz,
vor so einer Infektionswelle ist Quatsch. Und es gibt ja auch genug Belege mittlerweile haben wir, glaube ich, hier auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, dass,
immer wieder mal alte Blutproben geöffnet werden, so Ende zwanzig neunzehn uns dann
immer mal wieder Leute äh gibt, also immer wieder mal so Proben gefunden werden, wo mal ein Test drauf gemacht wird, wo man sieht, so aha
da war der Virus eigentlich auch schon da.
Mhm. Ja, es sieht ja auch so aus, dass er ähm sagen schon ein, zwei mal vorher eingeschleppt äh wurde als äh und,
mindestens bei einer Gelegenheit sich aber totgelaufen äh hat äh wohl.
Frankreich war das glaube ich, ne.
Nee, auch in Deutschland wohl.
Okay, aber ich kenne auch so einen Fall aus Frankreich. Mhm.
Ja, ja. Ja, aber vielleicht nochmal, um jetzt nochmal die, das mit den Deutschland äh Zahlen.
Abzuschließen, ähm so absolut sind.
Ist die Inzidenz jetzt bei R sechzehn Komma vier äh neue Fälle, je hunderttausend,
Einwohner bundesweit. Ähm wir haben ja so diverse Grenzen von dreißig oder fünfzig oder auch immer, wo es dann kritisch äh wird. So bei den Bundesländern,
überschreitet, dass keines interessanterweise haben wir jetzt vorne auch gerade Bremen, Berlin und Hamburg, was das angeht alle so mit zwischen,
achtundzwanzig Komma fünf und einunddreißig Komma zwei an sieben Tagesinstitenz, also die Ballungsräume äh sagen äh bei den bei den Ländern sind jetzt am meisten betroffen,
Ja ähm und.
Es gibt jetzt ja kein kein Land.
Wo also am besten steht Mecklenburg-Vorpommern im Moment da und Thüringen hat auch relativ niedrige Zahlen ja Saarland und,
Brandenburg, so stehen gerade eher noch am Ende der Tabelle und der Rest so dazwischen und.
Interessant, vielleicht auch noch bei den Top dreißig kommt seit über einer Woche kommt halt Hamm nicht äh.
Vom Spitzenplatz runter ähm ja, Remscheid an zweiter Stelle, aber haben,
Ähm ich weiß nicht, was da los ist, aber äh das kommt jedenfalls bisher noch nicht zur Ruhe, während es sich interessanterweise ja in Bayern ähm ja schon etwas.
Beruhigt hat. Bayern hat ja zwischenzeitlich so über die Hälfte äh der Top dreißig.
Bayerischen Landkreisen äh gefüllt und.
Deutlich runtergegangen. Jetzt ist es halt wieder NRW.
Berlin Mitte auch ziemlich weit vorne auf Platz fünf im Moment bei der Risikoliste.
Und überhaupt ziemlich viele Berliner Bezirke in den Top dreißig.
Gerade Reinickendorf und Wilmersdorf und Tempelhof-Schöneberg und Friedrich Friedrichshain Kreuzberg.
Ja ähm.
Also in Hamm ist glaube ich war glaube ich gab so eine Großhochzeit die so ein bisschen daneben gegangen ist und äh das scheint so ein bisschen einer der Faktoren gewesen zu sein.
Ja, das ist aber auch schon ein bisschen eine Weile her und wenn's so ein Einzelausbruch ist, dann gibt's nach einer Woche gehen die Zahlen halt runter.
Haben ja gehen sind sie immer noch nicht runtergegangen. So, das ist ja, schauen wir mal.
Ansonsten ja eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs.
Landkreise, die die fünfzig diese berühmte Grenze von fünfzig vierhunderttausend Fällen überschreiten, also eine,
noch Römscheid und Berlin Mitte mit achtundfünfzig drei.
Berlin Neukölln mit zweiundfünfzig acht. Dann haben wir noch Cloppenburg und Rhön.
Grabfeld. So, das sind so im Moment die Corona Hotspots in Deutschland.
Höhen Grabfeld. Verweisungsvoller Name.
Äh ja also.
NRW, Bayern, Berlin, NRW, Bayern, Berlin.
Etwas weniger Baden-Württemberg, wenn ich das so richtig rauslese, das hat sich etwas äh beruhigt, da kommen erst so äh später die kritischen Landkreise.
Ja, Biberach. Biberach ist.
Ja, es geht dann auch irgendwann los ähm so, nur nicht ganz so wild wie ähm in den anderen.
Ne, definitiv. Also ein bisschen, ja, bisschen Schleswig-Holstein ist auch noch mit einem Landkreis, mit Flensburg interessanterweise und Dietmarschen sind noch in den Top,
dreißig und ja also das dazu und.
Wie schon erwähnt, äh sie Testzahlen der letzten Woche ähm wir haben zweitmeisten Tests seit,
Beginn der Tests in der letzten Woche, also da hat sich im Wesentlichen, in den letzten drei Wochen nicht viel getan bei der Zahl der Tests, aber äh wir sehen da eine deutlich,
ansteigende positiven,
Quote jetzt in den in den letzten drei Wochen, also das heißt, da ist definitiv ähm.
Musik drin.
Infektionsaktivität, ja also weil die die Quote ja ist, also,
Tiefstand war in Kalenderwoche sechsunddreißig, vor vier Wochen beziehungsweise das ist nicht der absolute Tiefstand, aber äh mir der absolute Tiefstand war irgendwann in Kalenderwoche, achtundzwanzig, wo wir nur null Komma fünf, neun
Prozent,
positiven Quote hatten und jetzt seit in den letzten vier Wochen sind von null Komma sieben vier auf null Komma acht sechs,
eins Komma eins sechs eins Komma eins zwei. Äh nee eins Komma zwei zwei.
Eins Komma zwei aktuell positiven Quote und bei eins Komma eins fünf Millionen Tests, die.
Gemacht worden.
Interessant finde ich auch, ähm bei dieser Aufzählung, die wir hier gerade zitierst, äh wird ja auch noch die Anzahl der übermittelnden Labore genannt,
Das waren dann letzte Woche insgesamt zweihunderteins Labore. Jetzt sind es irgendwie neunzehn Labore weniger.
Ich freue mich wie sich das erklärt. Könnte mir nur vorstellen, dass das damit zu tun hat, dass diese ganzen Reiserückrückkehrer Laborstationen bisschen zurückgebaut wurden.
Ja, entweder das oder ich meine, das schwankt ja,
immer einen ein bisschen und vielleicht manche Labore setzen dann auch auch aus oder so, weiß ich nicht. Äh ja,
auf auf jeden Fall ja haben wir einen realen Anstieg gerade zu verzeichnen in Deutschland der sich auch nicht mit irgendwelchen ja.
Testausweitungszahlen oder sowas erklären lässt. Und wie gesagt bei der Frage, wie es jetzt weitergeht.
Kann niemand genau vorhersagen auch äh ja beim mit dem RKI Nowcast sieht man, dass der alles offen lässt.
Für die nächsten zwei Wochen, wenn die Zahlen also hoch oder runter gehen,
da äh deutet sich kein klarer Trend an, was aber auch ganz gut ist. Also die Zahlen scheinen zumindest noch nicht zu explodieren.
Aber.
Sagt mit genug Zeit reicht auch der Anstieg den wir im Moment sehen aus damit äh es irgendwann ungemütlich wird und,
voraussichtlich selbst wenn's nicht schlimmer wird, sondern selbst wenn's jetzt nur so weiter ansteigt mit einem R,
um die eins Komma eins was wir gesehen haben.
Ja ähm ist das nicht äh auszuhalten, das ist halt nicht nachhaltig. Das ja auch da werden wir irgendwann dann.
An die Grenzen des Gesundheitssystems stoßen, wobei das im Moment noch nicht wirklich sichtbar ist. Also.
Nee, also ich glaube auch die Zahl der belegten Betten, die ist noch nicht nennenswert gestiegen. Also, ich meine, die Zahl der Toten, wir haben vorhin gesagt, die geht hoch. Ja, wir sind jetzt, glaube ich, so bei zwölf.
An einem Tag gewesen, ne? Und ähm alles nicht schön, aber.
Ist natürlich jetzt auf die gesamte Republik und auf die gesamte Krankenhauskapazität
natürlich noch keine bedrohliche Zahl, also das ist natürlich jetzt nicht zwölf Leute, die jetzt gerade im Krankenhaus liegen, sondern die ist irgendwie höher, die weiß ich jetzt nicht, die haben wir jetzt nicht ermittelt, aber äh definitiv sind die Krankenhäuser jetzt auch nicht gerade,
mit Patienten, die dringend behandelt werden müssen.
Nee, es wurden auch normale, wieder normale Operationen hochgefahren. Wir haben immer die Intensivbetten, habe ich gesehen, sind so zwischen achtzig und neunzig Prozent wieder belegt, also ein bisschen Kovetreserve gibt,
im Moment noch äh normal sind, glaube ich, so neu zwischen neunzig und fünfundneunzig Prozent der Intensivbetten ausgelastet,
wenn wir jetzt so um die achtzig Prozent haben, heißt das, wir haben so zehn Prozent Kowit-Reserve äh im Moment gerade
Was jetzt nicht so super üppig ist, weil wir hatten mal fünfzig Prozent, aber das hat sich dann offenbar als äh ja.
Dann zum Glück nicht erforderlich rausgestellt.
Ja, also.
Auch was nachzutragen zu den Zahlen.
Nö, ich glaube mit den Zahlen äh war's das soweit nichts erregendes.
Noch ein Blick auf Berlin selber nochmal werfen.
Also Berlin ist ja immer äh oder.
War oft so ein bisschen Vorreiter für Bundestrends mehrfach, also wenn's in Berlin angezogen ist, ist im Bund dann danach angezogen und wenn's dann in Berlin ab
gefallen ist es dann im Bund. Danach abgefallen. Insofern war Berlin immer so ein bisschen so ein nicht immer, aber äh so teilweise
geeigneter Frühindikator.
Sag es Trendsetter, Berlin ist.
Trendsetter.
Das ist das, was wir hören wollen.
So können wir das dann auch nochmal positiv deuten.
Genau und ähm ja, wenn man jetzt Berlin als Trendcenter äh sieht,
heißt das jetzt nicht unbedingt was Gutes. Äh wir hatten.
In der letzten Woche ein kurzes innehalten so wo äh nach einem ziemlich steilen Anstieg und jetzt aber aktuell letzten Zahlen,
heute geht's.
Auch wieder steil nach oben. Ähm ja, also von Berlin geht derzeit keine Hoffnung auf Verlangsamung oder Rückgang unbedingt.
Aus, muss man sagen, kein neuer Trend. Einziges in Berlin sterben keine Leute oder,
so gut wie keine Leute äh noch weniger als im Bundesdurchschnitt, also im letzten Monat sind, glaube ich, zwei oder drei Leute äh gestorben.
In Berlin und zwischenzeitlich manchmal für zwei Wochen niemand und ja das ist also sagen wir mal soweit erfreulich,
Ja, ansonsten, ich weiß nicht, wie dein Eindruck ist, draußen so, ich hatte jetzt das Gefühl, gerade in den letzten wärmeren Tagen, dass irgendwie,
alle nochmal unbedingt raus mussten und irgendwie unbedingt.
Die letzte Sonne noch mitnehmen. Auf jeden Fall, ja, das war äh ganz wichtig, inwiefern das dann nochmal zu irgendeiner Verschärfung geführt hat
lässt sich schwer sagen. Ich habe ja insgesamt das Draußensein relativ wenig in Verdacht. Ich denke, das ist halt einfach eher das Drinten sein, dass die Leute da einfach ähm nachlässig geworden sind. Ich habe so viele Kneipen gesehen, wo die Leute dann einfach rumsitzen, ohne Masten und so weiter und
Ich denke mir dann nur so, ja, okay, meinetwegen, aber.
Ich, ich habe noch nicht mit meinem Leben abgeschlossen, macht ihr das mal? Ähm das das Dumme ist und das haben wir ja auch schon mehrfach beklagt, dass.
Dass wir einfach also ich weiß nicht, ob wir keine Zahlen bekommen oder ob wir sie noch nicht hören.
Aber ich vermisse einfach in dieser ganzen Begleitung, dieser Pandemie mal klarere Einschätzungen darüber, was sind die Gesundheitsämter so ermittelt haben.
Was sind die Ursachen sind? Wo, bei welcher Gelegenheit haben sich die Leute angesteckt,
Ja, man hört halt immer wieder von ja die Hochzeit hier, der Restaurantbesuch da, das sind dann halt immer diese Großereignisse, aber wir wissen auch, dass diese Information ermittelt wird beim Gesundheitsamt und damit wird sie dann auch,
gemeldet. Sie erscheint halt bloß nicht in den veröffentlichten Daten, die wir auswerten.
Es gab mal so ein paar dann über die Presse verbreitete Bestandsaufnahmen in Berlin und ich glaube auch in anderen äh Ländern auch und da,
kam, ja das war vor drei Wochen hatten wir dann, glaube ich, auch hier in der Sendung äh thematisiert. Ähm dass,
angeblich demnach so die Hälfte der Infektionen im privaten Umfeld, also in den Haushalten eigentlich stattgefunden hat und die andere Hälfte sich angeblich breit verteilt hat,
Und ähm ja aber.
So das zu beobachten, wie sich das wandelt, wie sich die Maßnahmen auswirken. Äh da vermisse ich auch Fachinformationen von den Gesundheitsämtern, was sind denn jetzt die gefährlichen.
Gehen. Ach ja und es gab jetzt erstmals 'ne Studie ähm zu einer Verbreitung in einem äh auf einem Flug, also in einem,
in einem Flugzeug, weiß nicht ob du davon gehört hast.
Nein.
Und zwar hat es allerdings wohl schon im März stattgefunden. Das war also noch in der Zeit bevor Leute.
Masken äh auf Flügen getragen haben und äh überhaupt,
ja, also es war sagen ja im, wie gesagt, im März, als es gerade so losging und äh aber die äh äh Flieger noch unterwegs waren, da hat.
Eine äh.
Eine Passagierin hat glaube ich neunzehn Leute insgesamt angesteckt.
Die flog in der ersten Klasse und,
aber auch Leute angesteckt, mit denen sie eigentlich im Flieger gar nicht in Kontakt gekommen sein kann, sodass dort die Vermutung ist.
Dass es entweder beim am Check-in-Schalter möglicherweise passiert ist oder dann bei der Einreise, bei der
eben in der Passschalter Schlange, weil anders lassen sich manche Ansteckungen wohl wohl nicht äh äh,
erklären, aber.
Über die Toilette.
Ähm über die Toilette möglicherweise so aber wohl auch nicht komplett. Also es gibt weiß, hat wohl mehrere Passagiere, die wo man definitiv weiß, dass die nicht,
äh die Toilette mitbenutzt haben und äh also keine andere äh eine andere Toilette benutzt haben und so weit weg saßen das eigentlich
so im Flieger das nicht passiert sein kann. Das wirft natürlich
auch nochmal ein anderes Licht auf andere Transportmittel jetzt eben wie Busse und Bahnen, weil eigentlich äh
wir davon ausgegangen sind, weil man davon ausgehen kann, dass Flugzeuge aufgrund der Art, wie die klimatisiert und belüftet sind zu den sichersten Verkehrsmitteln
zählen. Und äh wenn man jetzt aber Übertragung im Flugzeug auch hatte, heißt es natürlich, dass es vermutlich
auch Übertragungen in anderen Verkehrsmitteln äh gegeben hat und.
Möglicherweise auch auch gibt. So, dass äh ja nur, dass man.
Dass das offenbar nicht erfasst wird. Also wenn man sich in der U-Bahn ansteckt oder im,
im Bus oder so, dann ja äh ist das wahrscheinlich wird das wahrscheinlich nie auffallen, dass das dort passiert ist.
Kann schon sein. Immer noch keinen Grund, nicht mal die Erkenntnisse des Gesundheitsamts auch irgendwie ein bisschen in die Welt zu tragen, um es einfach besser einschätzen zu können oder besser auch Warnungen aussprechen zu können.
Sie hatten dort extrem wenige, wo sie,
ist nicht zuordnen konnten, das kam ja auch ein bisschen komisch vor, also es waren wirklich nur eine Handvoll, wo sie dann gesagt haben, also unter zehn Prozent, wo die wo sie angeblich nicht,
äh rausfinden konnten, wo die sich angesteckt haben. Ja, aber leider ja,
behalten die Gesundheitsämter das offenbar gerne für sich oder haben niemanden, der sich die Arbeit machen könnte, das mal in die Öffentlichkeit zu tragen oder regelmäßig in die Öffentlichkeit zu tragen
Also offiziell ist weder Berlin als Ganzes ein Risikogebiet noch dein Wohnbezirk im Moment. Äh so.
War auch nur ein Scherz.
Aber äh so wenn du in Mitte wohnen würdest, äh könntest du äh sagen, wäre es kein Scherz.
Ja gut, das ist auch nicht so weit weg. So, also meines, es ist halt alles äh.
Also wenn man sich überhaupt durch die Stadt bewegt, dann bewegt man sich im Zweifelsfall auch an Leuten entlang, die unter anderem auch in Mitte wohnen. Ich meine, was heißt denn das? Ein Fall in Mitte, ist das jemand, der in Mitte arbeitet oder ist das jemand, der in Mitte wohnt,
Wohnt überhaupt irgendjemand in Mitte? Also das finde ich halt auch so ein bisschen dünner, ne? Also.
Ja, das.
Klar, es ist halt das Gesundheitsamt, was das irgendwie meldet, aber wo das jetzt tatsächlich passiert, ja? Also äh kann ich darum damit auch nicht rauslesen.
Was auch nochmal eine erweiterte Kritik sein könnte. Na ja, auf jeden Fall ich möchte mich natürlich gerne von einem fernhalten und habe halt jetzt äh mir eben überlegt, okay, wie machst du das jetzt? Ich hatte ja auch schon letztes Mal
erzählt, wie das so in etwa läuft, sprich ich meide jetzt erstmal die Bahn.
Und ähm vielleicht tue ich der Bahn auch unrecht. Ich höre halt dieses und ich höre halt jenes. Ich bin aber einfach derzeit schlicht auf dem.
Alle Unwäldbarkeiten erstmal ausschließen, bleiben noch genug übrig. So, Modus.
Und deswegen beiße ich da ein bisschen den saueren Apfel, weil ich habe nun wirklich nicht unbedingt.
Tausende von Kilometern mit dem Auto abzureißen, ne? Also allein schon.
Umwelt äh äh technisch ist das natürlich alles nicht so wünschenswert, aber da mangelt's mir jetzt gerade so ein bisschen an Optionen,
Und ich habe natürlich dann immer auch das Problem, ich muss halt auf Leute treffen und wenn ich dann halt mit denen irgendwie na ja zwei Stunden irgendwie in einem Raum sitze, um mich mit ihnen zu unterhalten
dann kann ich natürlich da auch irgendwie nicht groß mit Masten äh Gemuffel arbeiten, also muss das irgendwie anders hinbekommen und abgesehen von den naheliegenden Dingen wie großen Abstand halten, gut durchlüftet und so weiter, Fenster offen halten, et cetera mache ich halt dann eben auch noch.
Freiwillige Tests, damit ich zumindest mir halbwegs sicher bin. Jetzt habe ich ja letztes Mal schon erzählt, ich war in Düsseldorf da bei dieser Walk-In-Box, diesen Container, der da äh auf dem Hauptbahnhof rumsteht oder zumindest damals rumstand, weiß ja nicht, ob das noch ein Betrieb ist.
Und das lief ja soweit ähm ganz gut und jetzt ähm stand aber eine neue Reise an und äh habe ich halt mal geguckt, was mache ich jetzt.
Und diesmal habe ich zurückgegriffen,
auf einen PCR-Test für zu Hause, der von der niederländischen Firma Sentogen angeboten wird oder Sentojin, Zentogene geschrieben, die ähm ja in Deutschland halt.
Drei Labore glaube ich unterhalten und dort entsprechende Coronatests machen.
Und da klickt man sich halt auf Amazon einfach so eine Box, die kostet neunundsiebzig Euro, das ist ein kleiner Karton. Da ist im Prinzip nur ein Testkit drin, also du hast halt so ein Trümmel, den du dir dann irgendwie in deine Rachen schieben kannst.
Äh und das machst du dann halt, schiebst das Ding irgendwie in den Hals und versuchst immer so ein bisschen am.
Am Brechreiz entlang möglichst viel
Körperkontakt zu erzeugen und wenn ich das Gefühl habe, dass es jetzt irgendwie ausreichend gesättigt, dann schiebt man das halt in so eine kleine Plastikkanüle rein
bricht äh den Stab so ab, dass nur noch der untere Teil ähm drin bleibt, Schraubstes zu
packst es dann ins Tütchen und das Tütchen nochmal in ein Versandtütchen und ja.
Dann fragte ich mich hier so und jetzt, wie weiter, weil äh dieser Test ist ja dafür gedacht, dass du ihn na ja einsendest und ich dachte, in meinem Jugendlichen Leichtsinn bis dahin noch.
Einsenden heißt, ich laufe jetzt irgendwo zur Post und schmeiße das Ding irgendwo rein und dann kommt's halt morgen irgendwo an.
Na ja, weit gefehlt. Ähm das Ganze läuft halt so. Man klickt sich da einen Account auf dieser Webseite,
und der Test, den man zugesendet bekommt, der hat so eine Chargen-Nummer oder so eine, so ein, so eine Identifikationsnummer.
Um was sexuell siebenstelliges.
Und nachdem ich mich quasi so als Person da äh registriert habe, registriere ich quasi auch dieses Testkit.
Also diese Nummer ein und sagst so, alles klar, die ist jetzt fertig, die möchte ich jetzt gerne na ja zusenden ist halt nicht, sondern wie ich dann eben lernte, wird abgeholt.
Okay, gut, muss ich ja nirgendswo hinlaufen, ist mir auch recht. Kickt das halt irgendwie an und dann sagen sie, ja, super, holen wir ab. Nächstes Zeitfenster dann morgen äh von zwölf bis sechzehn Uhr.
War's ein bisschen blöd war für mich, weil ich halt irgendwie ein bisschen davon ausgegangen bin, dass ich das so bin, eines Tages mehr oder weniger gleich nach der Proben,
Entnahme oder Probenname ähm losschicken könnte, dass es dann eben zeitnah auch getestet wird.
Na ja okay, war dann nicht so sprich zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo es dann abgeholt wurde, war ich schon längst unterwegs.
Und dann äh hielt ich, also ich hab's quasi so am am Abend meine Probe gemacht, dann wurde es am nächsten Tag irgendwann so mittags abgeholt.
Dann.
Muss es ja noch versendet werden und dann am Folgetag um zehn Uhr erhielt ich dann eine E-Mail, wo drin scheint so, okay, alles klar ist angekommen. Wir testen jetzt.
Und dann hat's nochmal zwölf Stunden gedauert.
Bis dann die Nachricht kam, so okay, teste es durch, hier negativ alles gut. Und ja gut, dann äh habe ich wieder ein bisschen was gelernt, weil im Prinzip hatte ich dann das Testergebnis, nachdem alle meine Interviews dann schon gelaufen waren.
Nicht so ganz das was ich wollte in gewisser Hinsicht natürlich beruhigend, weil ich halt allen Gesprächspartnern sagen konnte so ja hier übrigens.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich jetzt während dieses Gesprächs in irgendeiner Form ähm infizierend äh hätte wirken können, die äh kann ich glaube ich ausschließen.
Trotzdem war das jetzt noch nicht unbedingt der optimale Verlauf. Ich habe da jetzt nochmal eine Anfrage laufen, nachdem man eine längere Mail geschrieben, wie denn das dann nun eigentlich so genau gedacht ist, wie man das äh optimieren kann. Äh weil klar, ich kann natürlich jetzt äh meinen Test,
meine meine Probenentnahme quasi.
So machen, dass ich sag OK hier bitte abholen, dann sagen die mir, wenn Sie es abholen und ich test halt, mach, mach die eigentliche Probenentnahme dann halt,
zehn Minuten bevor dieses Zeitfenster beginnt. Nur.
Das muss ich ja dann immer noch mit meiner Abreise irgendwie koordinieren. Also muss ich das dann sowieso etwas früher machen und dann ist halt immer die Frage, okay.
Wie alt ist denn dieser Test noch? Wie viel, wie viel ist er denn jetzt noch wert, ne, wenn es dann irgendwie auf einmal zwei, drei Tage her ist, dann,
sinken zwar die Wahrscheinlichkeiten, aber ist jetzt äh auch nicht unbedingt der Grad an Sicherheit, die man haben will.
Na ja, gut, aber funktioniert im Prinzip ist auch vergleichsweise günstig und ähm ja, kann man eigentlich empfehlen, für jemanden, der sich so Cashew mal testen möchte
gibt's auch noch als Familienpackung, dann kostet irgendwie nicht achtzig Euro, sondern hundert äh habe ich vergessen,
billiger auf jeden Fall äh einen Dutzend nehmen, Dutzend ist nicht, es sind dann vier Tests in einem. Sprich, wenn man halt so eine
klassische Durchschnittsfamilie damit auch noch testen lassen möchte, kann man das etwas günstiger haben, so für den Ausflug zu den Großeltern oder sowas, zum Absichern.
Und ja, in der Regel ist man innerhalb von zwei Tagen dann äh kann man sich halt irgendwie einen Befund geben lassen.
Was ich zu kritisieren habe, ist noch folgendes. Also erstmal halt diese ganzen Sachen mit dem schwierigen Timing,
dann wollte ich halt bei der Hotline anrufen, um mal diese ganze Frage zu stellen mit ja, wann testet ihr denn, macht ihr das auch am Wochenende? Muss ich, wenn ihr ein Wochenende dazwischen liegt, muss das noch früher machen, weil ich nicht weiß, wenn ihr's abholen kommt und so weiter und ähm.
Ja, natürlich war dann diese Hotline Dauer äh besetzt und irgendwann nach einer halben Stunde lässt man's dann auch nochmal sein. Und was mir auch noch ein bisschen merkwürdig vorkam,
sagen, dass sie halt diese Corona-Warn-App unterstützen. Das steht da irgendwie drauf. Ich sage so, oh geil,
Corona Warnap, alles super. Habe aber dann ähm sowohl in diesem Testkit als auch dann bei der Webseite ähm.
Kein QR-Code gefunden.
Den man jetzt hätte scannen können, weil das würde ich ja jetzt erwarten, dass in dem Moment, wo das, wo der Test abgeholt wird, spätestens dann auf der Webseite so ein QR-Code kommt mit hier das Ganze jetzt mal ein, damit ihr die Corona Warn-App Bescheid sagen kann.
Kam aber nicht und in diesem ganzen Prozess bis zu negativen Testergebnis habe ich halt sowas nicht gesehen und wenn wenn ich zwischen den Zahlen richtig lese, ist äh ihre Aussage nur, wenn du einen positiven Test von uns bekommst, dann kriegst du auch noch so einen Barcode,
kannst.
Der dann motiviziert wird, also sozusagen nur im Positivfalle, damit dann du auch automatisch dein Testergebnis äh freischalten kannst, ohne diese Teletan äh benutzen zu müssen.
Ja, sie benutzen also nicht das Meldefeature von der.
Doch sie benutzen das Melde.
Nicht das das sagen Mitteilungstestergebnis Mitteilungsfe.
Doch aber nur wenn's halt positiv ist,
in dem Moment, wo du das dann scannst, weißt du eh schon, dass du positiv bist, du scannst es nur, um dir dann nochmal von der App sagen zu lassen, dass das jetzt auch wirklich so war und äh äh damit du dann in der Folge ohne eine weitere Tat
so meine Vermutung, ohne dass natürlich jetzt konkret durchgelebt zu haben. Und das ist so ein bisschen.
Beyond the point, ne? Auf der anderen Seite kann man natürlich sagen, ja okay, E-Mail funktioniert auch.
Ist natürlich jetzt in puncto Datenschutz jetzt nicht ganz so da wo die Korona Warnapp ist so, weil.
Na ja, man kriegt halt eine E-Mail vom Testcenter, da weiß dann halt jeder schon mal Bescheid, der irgendwie die E-Mail äh äh mithört, da steht natürlich das Ergebnis nicht drin, aber.
Na ja, also ein gutes äh datenschutzfreundliches Design sieht ein bisschen anders aus, ist mir jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt egal, weil ich da jetzt auch nicht so das große Problem mithätte, selbst wenn ich irgendwie positiv bin, dann ist das halt so.
Na ja, also das kann sich auf jeden Fall noch verbessern und es ist generell noch sehr unübersichtlich,
wie gut eigentlich diese Corona Barn App äh jetzt von den Laboren unterstützt wird. Es gibt keine Aufstellung, es gibt da keine Webseite, wo steht diese Labore, machen's, diese Labore machen's nicht, das sind einfach alles so Sachen, die mir äh komplett fehlen und.
Ja, da können wir gleich auch nochmal äh einen Blick nach Europa werfen, wie's woanders aussieht.
Da ist auf jeden Fall eine äh Gelegenheit äh versäumt worden bisher
sagen auch ein bisschen Werbung oder Druck zu machen, wenn die Labore halt ja so damit werben
und sagen Corona Warnapp Unterstützung aber nur nur halb. Also will sagen.
Es wäre äh eigentlich eigentlich ganz, ganz gut, wenn's eben so eine Liste gäbe,
der Bundesregierung, die sagen, diese Labore sind voll angebunden, halb angebunden, gar nicht angebund,
man tatsächlich weil wir wissen, dass es,
das Potenzial hat Zeit zu sparen ähm äh ja schade.
Ja, ist schade. So und jetzt äh gibt es mittlerweile auch die lange Zeit.
Versprochenen Antigentests. Die sogenannten Schnelltests sind jetzt verfügbar, zumindest ist einer verfügbar.
Es ist der einzige von dem ich weiß, dass er verfügbar ist. Ähm ich vermute sogar ist es der einzige, der verfügbar ist, zumindest in Deutschland,
Ähm zur Erinnerung dieser Antigentests sind eine andere Art von Test mit einem anderen Ziel. Hier geht's vor allem dadrum, schnell ein Ergebnis zu bekommen.
Und die unterscheiden sich halt von dem PCR-Tests dadurch, dass sie einfach natürlich weniger Aufwand brauchen. Man braucht da eben kein Labor, man hat das Labor quasi in der Hand,
Ähm also man kann das quasi vor Ort machen und hat so einen kleinen Teststreifen, auf dem dann letzten Endes da so eine Lösung drauf geträufelt wird, die aus dem aus der Probe,
entstanden ist und dann kann man halt an so einem Strichlein sehen, okay positiv oder negativ.
Die sollen auch ganz gut funktionieren und sind halt dafür gedacht vor Ort eingesetzt zu werden. Also,
schnell. So. Man sagt fünfzehn Minuten dauert dieser ganze Prozess,
Der Test, der auf dem Markt ist es von der Firma Rosch und ich habe jetzt im Netz bei so Praxisdienstleistern,
gesehen, dass der so an Arztpraxen für einen Preis von zweihundertneunundzwanzig Euro netto ähm für fünfundzwanzig Tests verkauft wird. Also es läuft auf ungefähr neun Euro pro Testnetto
raus. Allerdings ist der jetzt nicht für alle
sondern da steht explizit drauf, ist nur für medizinisches Personal, ist kein Endkundentest et cetera und der Grund liegt darin, wohl begraben, dass hier
zumindest in der offiziellen Dokumentation, die ich gesehen habe ein Rachenabstrich durch die Nase.
Angesagt ist. Das ist ja nochmal so eine besonders eklige Geschichte, weil man ja da quasi sein.
So ein Stab dann äh quer durch die Nase geschoben bekommt und dann hinten da wo es schön äh äh weh tut, das ist ein Prozess musste ich bisher noch nicht machen,
Da wird dann halt diese Probe entnommen.
Und das ist nun irgendwie nichts, was man gerne selber macht und das halt auch in nichts, was man jetzt von irgendjemand machen lassen möchte, der es nicht
irgendwie, naja, gelernt hat oder zumindest schon mal weiß, was was er oder sie tut und ähm ja, deswegen ist es so. Sprich, der Test,
da, den Test kann man kaufen, er ist für Praxen gedacht, er ist natürlich vor allem auch für Kliniken gedacht, weil es ja quasi gerade man denkt jetzt mal so Notaufnahme und so weiter, ne. Irgendwelche Leute kommen rein, müssen schnell
ähm behandelt werden. Da möchte man natürlich relativ schnell sicher sein, dass hier kein zusätzliches Risiko gerade äh reingerollt wird,
Dafür ist es natürlich ideal geeignet, aber es ist natürlich auch geeignet für Veranstaltungen. Ne, machen wir uns nochmal klar,
Das Veranstaltungsbusiness ist vermutlich das Business, was am härtesten getroffen ist von dieser ganzen Krise.
Härter noch als Kneipen oder Restaurants, die schon hart getroffen sind, aber zumindest alle irgendwo zumindest ansatzweise auch eine Chance hatten äh in Betrieb zu gehen, aber der Großteil der Veranstaltung ist halt abgesagt.
Also es ist einfach.
Ist, besondere so, Konzerte und so und jeder, der halt in dieser Branche arbeitet und davon darauf angewiesen ist, dass zumindest mit irgendeiner Regelmäßigkeit sowas stattfindet.
Vielzahl von Leuten, die das betrifft, ne? Verleiher und ähm Leute, die da mitfahren, ne.
Bis hin zu auch Messebauern zum Beispiel bei.
Genau, Messe, fahrendes Volk. Und ja, da ist natürlich dann so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass man mit diesem Schnelltest zumindest in einem bestimmten Maße äh eine gewisse Sicherheit herstellen kann.
Vorreiter in dieser ganzen Debatte, was Schnelltests und Veranstaltungen betrifft ist ja hier mein mein Lieblingsverein Union Berlin
die sich dafür auch schon äh eine ordentlich blutige Nase geholt haben für ihre Vorstöße, weil das jetzt irgendwie nicht immer allen so gepasst hat, wie die das so ähm in den Raum
Tan haben, aber wir sagen halt ganz klar, na, hier Veranstaltungsbranche ist einfach hart getroffen. Wir müssen da kreative Lösungen machen und wir versuchen die auch zu erreichen und ja, die äh tun sich da mit der Wissenschaft zusammen und
versuchen halt im Rahmen des Möglichen das voranzubringen. Da wird dann wohl der nächste Schritt mit so einem,
Schnelltest äh gemacht werden. Wie das konkret abläuft und wann steht noch nicht fest, aber.
Ich vermute mal, das werden wir so über den über den Herbst und Winter,
werden wir mindestens weitere Tests in dieser Hinsicht sehen, wenn nicht sogar eben auch schon bestimmte Veranstaltungen, die auf dieser Basis laufen,
können, ne? Wenn Leute natürlich bereit sind, sich so einen Test zu unterziehen.
Das Ding war's zehn Euro kostet äh,
so im gut im Einkauf, aber wie auch immer, ja, als Veranstalter kriegt man wahrscheinlich, ja, sogar dann, wenn man tausend oder so abnimmt, vielleicht sogar günstigere,
Preise, aber die Größenordnung zumindest, ja klingt jetzt erstmal nicht prohibitiv, also könnte.
Du musst natürlich noch dazurechnen, du brauchst halt Personal, was diese Tests dann auch durchführt, ne? Also ich rede ja jetzt nur von dem eigentlichen Testkit und ähm.
Da muss man dann halt schauen, je nach Situation, man muss halt dann gucken, wie viele Leute hast du überhaupt zum Testen, ne, wie viel Personal brauchst du, wie viel Platz brauchst du, wie schnell soll das gehen und so weiter und äh du musst dann auch eine Notifizierungslogistik haben. Also das kann, glaube ich, auch,
schnell, äh, teuer, teuer werden, als dass man das jetzt hier nur mit neun Euro multipliziert pro Teilnehmer, sondern kommt dann wahrscheinlich mindestens nochmal dasselbe dazu,
Für den ganzen Aufwand, den du treiben musst pro Nase.
Trotz alledem sind natürlich Größenordnungen wie zwanzig fünfundzwanzig Euro pro Teilnehmer würden schon eine ganze Menge Veranstaltungen wieder möglich machen,
die derzeit so nicht denkbar sind.
Ja. Man muss natürlich auch dazu sagen, ich habe mir gerade auch letzte Woche nochmal etwas genauer angeschaut, gibt's ein paar,
schöne YouTube-Videos äh auch wie äh die Tests im Einzelnen, also wie so ein PCR-Test funktioniert und wie einen auch antigen Tests äh funktioniert und gibt auch noch eine.
Andere Variante von der PCA äh ähm die
auch nicht PCA heißt, sondern äh wo halt anders funktioniert, wo äh dann die mit DNA-Schleifen äh funktioniert. Aber egal, jedenfalls äh der Punkt,
Auf den ich hinaus wollte, ist dass ähm sagen diese Schnelltests.
Doch eine höhere äh Volz,
Negativberater haben als jetzt einen äh PCR äh Test wohl ähm also
scheint mir auch schlüssig zu sein, aber gerade für so ein Szenario äh wie Stadion oder Veranstaltung, wo du ja die Supersprayer äh vor allen Dingen äh
erkennen willst, sollte das eigentlich ganz gut funktionieren, weil gerade natürlich die Leute, die eben.
Halt die Leute, die besonders viel Virus absondern äh willst du halt erkennen und die dürftest du auch mit so einem Streifentest eigentlich recht zuverlässig äh,
erkennen, äh so wenn der richtig genommen wird, äh also wenn die Probe richtig genommen wird. Wobei selbst,
ich sag mal.
Wenn äh also eigentlich müsste aber äh selbst bei so einem Supersprayer, also jemand, der wirklich große Mengen an an Virus produziert und ausscheidet ähm
sollte so ein Test eigentlich nicht fehlschlagen und wenn du jemanden hast, der vielleicht jetzt infiziert ist, aber so so geringe Virusmengen ausschaltet, dass du sie mit dem Test nicht erfassen kannst, dann ist er wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich gefährlich,
ja das heißt von daher ähm ja.
Also der Test ist natürlich selber, also diese Antigentest zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass sie eben eine relativ große Virusmenge auch brauchen. Und damit eigentlich ohnehin nur anschlagen, bei Leuten, die auch gerade in ihrer infektiösen Phase sind,
während dieser PCR-Test halt das Virus gnadenlos nachweist. Selbst wenn da überhaupt nichts mehr infektiös ist. Ja.
Selbst wenn da nur noch tote Restmengen, ja.
In Stuhlproben und so weiter äh vier Wochen später ist dieser Test immer noch in der Lage, weil der einfach so hochsensibel ist. Und.
Dieser Test ist halt tatsächlich wirklich mehr für in the Wild gedacht, aber trifft dann, glaube ich, bei diesem Virus auch ganz gut das Profil, dass man eben so zwei, drei Tage der der Kern,
Infektiösität.
Noch am ehesten damit abfängt und eigentlich auch nur das Abfangen will, kann also durchaus sein, wie du ja schon richtig gesagt hast, da kommt einer rein, der war vor drei Tagen maximal infektiös und jetzt klingt das nur noch aus, ja?
Der Test schlägt nicht ein, die Person kommt ins Stadion, auf diese Veranstaltung, nur die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das dann eben zu so einem.
Diese Person dann ein Supersprayder ist, ist dann halt auch entsprechend geringer. Na ja.
Gut, ähm da wir äh ich habe noch so ein paar Kleinigkeiten noch mit äh eingesammelt, aber vielleicht sollten wir nochmal ganz traditionell die Frage mit der Kroner Warnapp nach äh vorne stellen.
Ähm da tut sich ein bisschen äh was.
Zunächst einmal ist es so, die,
Europäische Initiative, die ich hier schon mehrfach angekündigt hatte. Also, dass die Länder, die alle eine,
App haben, die kompatibel ist mit diesem Google Apple, Exposé Notification Framework.
Was wir von Anfang an auch gesagt haben, sich ohnehin als Standard durchsetzen wird.
Mittlerweile gibt's glaube ich so an die siebzehn Länder in Europa, müsste ich gleich nochmal nachzählen, die äh auf dieses Modell setzen, neu dazugekommen,
sind jetzt auch die Briten, die das ja schon vor einiger Zeit angekündigt haben, dass sie das tun wollen würden, jetzt haben sie sie auch draußen,
Sprich, der einzige wirkliche Player, der hier äh noch nicht mitspielen will, ist Frankreich
Alle anderen werden einfach über dieses europäische System verbunden werden und da steckt dann auch wieder,
Telekom und SAP dahinter, sprich die haben den Auftrag bekommen, hatten ja, glaube ich, ja auch schon gesagt, diese Infrastruktur aufzubauen,
auf Basis dieser Neuerung, die jüngst über von Apple und Google in dieses Exposa Notification Framework eingebaut wurden, nämlich dass es eben diese Unterscheidung gibt mit diesem Reisestatus, das heißt das Telefon weiß, ich bin halt außerhalb meines.
Gebiets, in dem ich mich normalerweise aufhalte, in dem Moment, wo ich,
positiv getestet werde und Schlüssel veröffentliche, wird diese Information mit an diese Schüssel rangehangen, sodass eben die Distributions,
Infrastruktur weiß, aha, okay, das war jetzt irgendwo im Ausland. Diesen Kiem muss ich nicht nur über meine nationalen Server verbreiten, sondern den packe ich halt auch nochmal auf diesen internationalen Server und dann ist halt immer die Frage,
was fasst man quasi jetzt international zusammen und was sich,
bisschen abzeichnet ist, dass es eben für bestimmte Regionen so Sammelserver gibt und die werden dann eben noch zusätzlich abgefragt. Das bedeutet auch, dass die Apps alle angepasst werden müssen, um quasi von mehr als einem Server
diese Informationen zu holen und sich auch erstmal die Information irgendwo herzuholen, wo welche Server denn das jetzt sind
ich erwarte also Updates für alle diese Apps, die das machen und zwar spätestens bis zum siebzehnten Oktober, nämlich das sei jetzt das Datum, wo das dann im,
genommen werden soll. Sprich in so knapp drei Wochen könnte das dann auch schon funktionieren, dass wir so ein ähm ja zumindest innereuropäischen Austausch haben, der auch ein bisschen über die EU hinausgeht.
Ja, dummerweise halt Frankreich nicht dabei, aber das ist halt so eine Bockigkeit dieses Landes weiß ich auch nicht genau, was da jetzt noch passieren muss. Ähm meine mit ihren Zahlen können sie jetzt nicht werben.
Finde ich. Muss nicht so so, guck mal hier, zentralisiertes System, wie geil das funktioniert und dann hast du halt so Katastrophenausbruch,
am Start, wie es halt in Frankreich leider noch der Fall ist. Ähm, will damit jetzt auch nicht sagen, ähm,
weil sie nicht auf die richtige App gesetzt haben, ist das jetzt so bei denen, also es hätte auch mit einer mit dem dezentralen Modell auch,
auch Scheiße laufen können, nur andersrum gibt's ja immer noch und es gibt da auch auf Twitter immer wieder Leute, die regelmäßig auf mich einschlagen, immer mit dieser These, weil ja,
dieser Google Apple Ansatz äh so datenschutzfreundlich ist, hätte man sich ja quasi die Schärfe vom Schwert genommen und äh würde eben jetzt mit so einer zahnlosen App,
suchen da dem, dem Virus zu beißen und das, das halte ich halt eigentlich auch für äh.
Unsinn. Also das das äh,
das hat das eine hat glaube ich mit dem anderen an der Stelle nichts zu tun. Es hatte einfach was damit zu tun mit wie viele Leute nutzen das
die Nützlichkeit dieser App steigt einfach mit ihrer Benutzung und da haben wir einfach noch nicht genug
Teilnahme erreicht, andere Länder sind da ein bisschen weiter vorne. Ich hoffe, dass sich das in Deutschland nochmal ein bisschen bessern wird
und äh es gibt durchaus auch Berichte
von Leuten, die gewarnt wurden und so weiter und dann auch selber positiv waren beim Test. Das ist jetzt nicht so in die Medien geraten und es ist uns auch sicherlich keine übermäßig großen Zahlen,
Aber es gibt das und es kann halt helfen und es schadet halt auch überhaupt nicht bei der Bekämpfung des Rests.
Ja, ich habe so in der Presse auch einige etwas despektierliche Äußerungen von äh Gesundheitsamt Mitarbeitern über die App
gehört so nach dem Motto ja äh nee die App bringt uns gar nichts ja so.
Wobei ich ja ähm
ich das doch ein bisschen bedauerlich finde insbesondere weil offensichtlich,
bei den Gesundheitsämtern eine falsche Vorstellung davon zu herrschen scheint was diese App äh äh ja äh tun.
Oder nicht kalt, ja.
Soll und kann oder nicht kann und ja ähm insofern
ja finde ich es dann äh etwas unglücklich, wenn sich dann Mitarbeiter von irgendeinem Gesundheitsamt X äh sagen
Dazu äußern die vielleicht gar keine Fälle großartig hatten in der in der äh Richtung oder so.
Aber der Punkt nur betonen ist ja äh ja das,
eventuell der eine oder andere dazu angehalten wird bei sich beim Gesundheitsamt zu melden und testen zu lassen der ansonsten.
Eben das nicht tun würde, so weil er keine Symptome zeigt und auch äh jetzt nicht benachrichtigt werden konnte, weil er.
Halt ja sich neben jemandem aufgehalten hat, den er nicht kennt irgendwo in einem Café oder in einem Zug oder weiß der Geier wo, so,
und äh ja und da kann man sagen solche Fälle gibt es und da kann man auch nur sagen, jeder Einzelne abgeschnittene Verbreitungsstrang äh so hilft.
Ja und kann sogar entscheidend sein.
Das Interessante ist, diese Inages NHS National Health Service, NHS.
Jetzt rausgekommen ist, hat, ich habe mir das aber noch nicht angeschaut, deswegen kann ich da nicht so richtig viel zu sagen, aber es gibt wohl da tatsächlich dieses Check-In-Feature für Orte, von dem wir gesprochen haben.
Und ähm das müsste man sich nochmal genauer anschauen, was da äh hintersteckt, inwiefern das problematisch ist, offensichtlich haben sie es aber geschafft, die App mit diesem Feature in den App Store reinzubekommen, also offensichtlich tut es nix, wo jetzt Apple und Google sofort etwas dagegen gehabt
äh hätten und das wäre ja sicherlich nochmal eine ganz interessante Geschichte.
Und vom RKI ähm verlautet auch, so hat zumindest heiße äh berichtet, dass sie ja
eigentlich planen möchten jetzt äh ihre ganzen Apps zusammen zuwerfen, um sozusagen ein eine Einheitsapp zu haben. Sprich
da ist ja diese Corona Barneb, nur ein Punkt, das andere ist diese Datenspendeapp. Ähm,
die dann in der Kombination sicherlich, glaube ich, für Apple schon eher äh etwas problematischer sein könnte, das weiß ich nicht so recht zu bewerten, wie inwiefern die damit glücklich sind, dass das sozusagen äh ein Ding wird,
Das ließe sich sicherlich kombinieren, aber äh heißt natürlich auch, dass hier zwei Kotbasen miteinander zusammengebracht werden, die erstmal auch überhaupt noch nichts miteinander zu tun haben
natürlich ganz sinnvoll wäre, eben, wenn's richtig implementiert ist, dann müsste man sich nochmal ein bisschen dazu Gedanken machen, was sind nun eigentlich die sinnvollste Implementierung wäre.
Dass man eben diese ganze Check-In-Geschichte mit ich war hier. Ich war an diesem Ort ohne jetzt permanent überall immer wieder irgendwie seine Adresse aufschreiben zu müssen. Ja, dass man das irgendwie machen kann,
bin ja in letzter Zeit auch viel Gedanken darüber gemacht, weil dieses ganze Aufschreiben von Adressen hält einfach glaube ich sehr, sehr, sehr viele Leute davon ab, daran auch teilzunehmen. Also man meidet dann diese Listen dann doch eher
wenn man's wenn man nicht explizit dran erinnert wird und es natürlich auch nervig für Leute, die so in Restaurants arbeiten, die Leute auch die ganze Zeit so Scheiße zu nerven, das äh zu tun,
und am Ende weiß er eh nicht, ob das, was da reingeschrieben wird, irgendwie stimmt.
Und ich dachte mir so die ganze Zeit, es wäre doch eigentlich viel cooler, wenn ich mir irgendwo,
beim bei irgendeinem Registrierungsservice äh quasi so einmal meine Daten hinterlege und mir dann so einen Kürzel zuteilen lassen kann,
Weißt du, dass ich also anstatt Name, Telefonnummer, E-Mail, Adresse einfach in so einen Bogen reinschreiben kann.
L acht neun BDX F. So.
Oder etwas, was man sich vielleicht etwas einfacher merken kann und keine Fehler machen kann. Weil das erfüllt dann letzten Endes den selben Zweck, wenn ein Gesundheitsamt sozusagen über dieses Kürzel Zugriff auf diese Information hätte.
Ähm.
Nur mal so als Gedanke, also irgendwas muss da passieren. Das ist das ist so einfach total unpraktikabel und kein Wunder, dass man dann eben nicht richtig nachvollziehen kann. Äh wer denn da noch alles gewesen sein könnte.
Anderer Kritikpunkt, äh, den wir hier auch schon hatten, war ja diese Sache mit den Statistiken.
Warum kriegen wir nicht mehr Statistiken? Es gab ja einmal diese Auswertung von der Telekom, wo die achtzehn Millionen Downloads so in vierzehn Millionen aktive äh äh Apps übersetzt wurden, seitdem war da schon wieder Ruhe, ne?
Und dass das auch anders geht, zeigen andere Apps. Ich habe hier so ein kleines Screenshot von diesem Kurve-Tracker, das ist die irische äh App und,
steht halt direkt auf dem Mainscreen. So und so viel Active-Users, ja? Also sie sagen explizit, so und so viel.
So viel Prozent äh der Leute, die über sechzehn sind in Irland benutzen das, in dem Fall sind es vierunddreißig Prozent, durchaus bemerkenswerte Zahl so und zu viele Leute,
haben hier IDs hochgeladen,
und so und so viele Alarme wurden irgendwie auch ausgelöst, ne? Also es sind alles Informationen, die man letzten Endes auch auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise ähm.
Auswerten kann. Man muss halt nur richtig machen. Würde ich mir wünschen, dass das stattfindet.
Also unbedingt der Feature-Regfest irgendwie auch für die deutsche App, weil ja, ich finde.
Das ist ja jedenfalls interessant äh es zu wissen. Da sind uns also die Iren dann voraus.
Sind sie. Ja.
Dann gibt's noch so ein paar äh Kleinigkeiten, die mir so über den Weg gelaufen sind, die vielleicht mal ganz äh wertvoll sind, äh angesprochen zu werden, wo wir schon bei Irland sind.
Äh auf der irischen Webseite, wo es so rund um Corona äh Viros gibt, gibt's so eine schöne Grafik, die verlinken wir mal.
Wir haben die hier in den Shownotes, falls ihr das mal kurz anschauen willst, Pavel.
Ja, ich.
Hast du schon hier das National Framework von Living Visco und ich ich solche Sachen mag ich einfach,
Weil wir hatten das ja nun schon auch oft so, die Regeln ändern sich am laufenden Meter. Bei uns sind sie dann noch vom Bundesland zum Bundesland verschieden, et cetera und man weiß halt irgendwie immer nicht Bescheid. Und hier gibt's mal so eine Tabelle,
die die Sache relativ klar macht. Erstmal gibt's halt so einen fünf Stufenwarnsystem.
Ja, also je nachdem wie wie die Re Nummer ist, äh wobei wie das Mepping jetzt hier ist, weiß ich nicht, aber je nach Zustand von R
gibt's dann hier einen entsprechenden Level, sprich Level eins ist bei niedrigem Stand von R Level äh fünf ist äh bei einem hohen Stand von R.
Diese Levels werden so deutlich das jetzt mal ausgerufen. Man sagt einfach, wir sind jetzt auf Level, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf und dann hast du eben,
Das sind die Spalten und dann hast du eben äh Zeile für Zeile
Die einzelnen Kategorien von Dingen, die so stattfinden können, an denen man vielleicht teilnehmen wollen würde. Ne, fängt an hier mit Social and Family Gotherings, also einfach so Familie zusammen, ne, da geht's dann bis Level drei ab Level vier ist nicht mehr
Weddings, Hochzeiten.
Äh ja, geht's bei Level eins mit irgendwie hundert Leuten los und bei Level fünf dürfen da maximal sechs Leute noch rumstehen. Das reicht dann, glaube ich, gerade mal für einen Elternteil und ein Trauzeugen und.
Die die heiraten wollen und Pastor vielleicht noch, dein Trauzeug ist wahrscheinlich schon nicht mehr dabei
und so weiter, Indoor-Events, Outdoor-Events, Sport, Training, äh, Matches und Events, also Fußball, dann hier Schwimmbad, äh, Kirche, Bars
da auch die schöne Kategorie Wedpups, das muss ich auch erstmal nachschlagen, weißt du was was ein Wedpub ist.
Wo es nichts zu essen gibt.
Genau, richtig.
Hotels et cetera. Also die Liste ist relativ lang, Public Transport et cetera und ja das äh auf einer äh schönen ähm Tabelle, wo man sofort sehen kann, wie gerade so die Begrenzung ist.
Also was man darf oder mit wie vielen Leuten man was tun darf et cetera.
Ja. Dann ähm und ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr da schon mal drüber gesprochen haben.
In äh Helsinki am Flughafen setzen die jetzt wohl ernsthaft und ich hatte das schon mal gehört, dass das wohl grundsätzlich möglich ist.
Hunde ein, die sie wohl irgendwie auf Corona Virus trainiert bekommen haben.
Der ähm also ich wir hatten glaube ich noch nicht darüber gesprochen, aber ich habe.
Selber darüber nachgedacht, äh so dass es eigentlich möglich sein müsste, äh Hunde äh dazu zu trainieren und sagen, Corona infizierte
zu ja ersnifen
wahrscheinlich weil ja anhand bestimmter Stoffwechselprodukte die dann präsent sind äh denke ich müsste das eigentlich möglich sein.
Also ich habe die Einschätzung auch schon sehr früh äh gesehen, dass also Leute, die sich mit diesem Feld auskennen, der Meinung waren, dass das schon ginge und dass sie das mit anderen Viren wohl auch schon äh hinbekommen haben. Ja und hier sieht es wohl so aus, als ob.
Eben die tatsächlich im Einsatz sind. Das ist natürlich sehr interessant.
Ähm und zwar sprechen die hier von äh hundert Prozent Acuracy.
Ganz ordentliche Zahl ist, ne? Also einschließlich Virus äh die Sektion bevor irgendwelche Symptome da sind. Gut, das würde man dann in dem Fall natürlich auch,
erwarten.
Ja und die ähm denken halt, dass die Hunde einfach besser funktionieren, also die aktuellen äh die halt auf molekularer Ebene versuchen, das nachzuweisen. Also besser als PCR.
Gut, na ja, sie haben sozusagen äh.
Wenn sie sie an was so eine okay, das war in in Hannover sogar eine andere Test, wo äh,
die Bundeswehr den gemacht hat, wo sie die Hunde an.
Proben erhaben, schnüffeln lassen und so sagen neunundvierundneunzig Prozent.
Success Rate Overall, was auch immer äh das sein mag
aber ja ne finde ich denke, dass es auf jeden Fall äh wahrscheinlich eine super Sache so für ja Flughäfen und
andere äh ja Reise äh Zentren.
Also man darf sich das jetzt auch nicht so vorstellen äh dass da die Hunde jetzt irgendwie durch den Flughafen rennen und dann irgendwelch anfangen Leute anzukläffen, so funktioniert das nicht. Sagen wir es mal, wo machen muss es, man muss seine Haut äh äh abwischen mit so einem Stofftuch,
man kriegt da so ein Swipe, so ein Vibe in die Hand, ähm wischt sich damit die Haut ab und tut das in so eine Tasse.
Und das wird dann dem Hund gegeben und der Hund schnüffelt daran halt rum. Also im Prinzip Hautgeruch. Was was ich mega absurd finde, aber das die Zahlen sprech.
Nee, ich, ja, ich.
Für sich, ne? Man fragt sich eben nur, wie kriegt man das Hunden so rein trainiert, ne?
Belohnungssystem äh etablieren, mit dem sie das dann irgendwie machen, ne.
Wobei ähm fällt mir gerade ein, ich weiß nicht, äh hast du, ich glaube,
Deutsch heißt es, sie belieben äh zu scherzen, Mister Fineman, wo äh Finder ja berühmte Physiker
er hat ziemlich abgefahrene Sachen auch gemacht außerhalb der Physik zum Beispiel eine Sache war, dass er
sagen wie kann ich wach bleiben während ich schlafe also sozusagen wach wach träumen aber 'ne andere Sache die er auch gemacht hat ist sein Geruchssinn zu trainieren eigentlich der menschliche Geruchssinn ist eigentlich auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Nur wir nutzen den halt kaum und hat sagen selber dann geübt und trainiert selber halt Fährten
zu suchen und war dann festgestellt, dass sogar man auch als Mensch in der Lage ist, äh zum Beispiel, wenn man ein bisschen übt, tatsächlich.
Von jemanden, der irgendwo langgegangen ist, äh, am Boden zu erschnüffeln,
man kann das sogar als Mensch riechen, weil auch ja zwar die Hunde können das zwar viel besser, aber ja das gibt einem dann so ein bisschen eine Vorstellung davon. Äh ja,
wie gut die sind und letztlich in in der Nase ist es wohl so, dass,
es dort Sensoren gibt, die fast ja einstellige Zahlen an Molekülen, wenn die präsent äh sind, detektieren können, also
auch unglaublichen ähm ja Genauigkeit.
Also die äh ausbildende Institutionen nennt sich irgendwie mal so Hundetrainer aus Finnland. Also das ist dann sozusagen auch äh ein Produkt des äh Landes,
Ja, mal gucken, ob das eine.
Methode ist, die noch auf andere Länder dann überschlägt, meine Hunde werden sich auch woanders äh trainiert, nur vielleicht eben noch nicht auf das Richtige in dieser Hinsicht.
Und das wäre, ich nehme auch mal an, dass so Hunde, ich weiß nicht, die die werden ja dann wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann müde werden und so, also die können ja nicht dauerhaft so.
Ja, ja. Nee.
In Beschlag genommen werden, also braucht man dann entweder mehrere Hunde, wenn man da die ganze Zeit was testen möchte.
Ja, das ist wohl definitiv.
Oder eben nur so in so Zeiten, aber es geht halt, ne? Und das äh das ist natürlich dann eine eine tolle Methode.
Dann gab's noch so eine Meldung ähm dass dieser.
Dass dieser Immunitätsnachweis von diesem Ethikgrad abgelehnt wird, da hatte ich auch mit Linus bei LNP schon drüber gesprochen.
Äh sehr nachvollziehbar, aber der wesentliche Grund ist einfach der, dass eben diese ganze Nachweis von Antikörpern derzeit noch sehr schädig ist. Also man weiß einfach, gerade noch nicht so recht,
was ich eigentlich an Antikörpern so wirklich nachhaltig ähm,
feststellen lässt, also sowohl, dass Leute, die es mal gehabt haben, irgendwann keine Antikörper mehr haben oder zumindest bestimmte Antikörper nicht und das.
Ist einfach also diese Vorstellung,
dass wir irgendwann mal so einen einfachen Test haben und alle Leute kriegen so einen grünen Punkt auf die Stirn mit dir, du hast es schon mal gehabt, your free to go. Das äh,
Ja, davon scheinen wir noch relativ weit entfernt zu sein und dementsprechend wäre halt auch so ein Immunitätsnachweis derzeit einfach noch überhaupt nicht leistbar.
Artikel steht auch, dass wie dieser Ethikrat jetzt wohl nicht grundsätzlich dagegen ist,
zu so ein Instrument zumindest sie sagen Anlass bezogen und preisspezifisch unter bestimmten Bedingungen so, also äh sagen,
dass selbst wenn irgendwann.
Naturwissenschaftlichen Grundmedizinischen Voraussetzungen gegeben wären
so wär's irgendwie kein allgemeines Ding so nach dem Motto
hier ich brauch keine Maske in der Öffentlichkeit zu tragen oder so, weil hier ist mein Immunitätsausweis, sondern ich denke, äh, dass sie das dann
Vor allem, wenn dann vielleicht für medizinisches Personal zum Beispiel oder äh Leute, die
bestimmten gefährlichen Stellen arbeiten, wo sie entweder selber exponiert sind oder dann auch ja,
nur für ganz spezifische Dinge der taugen wird. Ja.
Wo wir äh schon bei Finnland waren, was wohl auch ganz gut funktioniert hat in äh Finnland ist, dass sie auch noch dieses Problem, dieses Koviotenproblem versuchen, dadurch,
in den Griff zu kriegen, indem sie explizit Social Influencers ansprechen und die für ihre Sache gewinnen.
Also die sind da äh quasi ein ein bekannte Leute herangetreten, die eben.
Reichweite haben, um dafür zu sorgen, dass über diese Kanäle Informationen weitergegeben werden.
Wurde wohl irgendwie direkt vom ähm von der Ministerpräsidentin.
Ausgelöst ist auch also erstens 'ne Frau wie der Name schon sagt und zwei ist auch relativ jung irgendwie vierunddreißig, also gebt einer gerade.
Ist glaube ich das ganze Kabinett ist irgendwie extrem weiblich und extrem äh jung oder verwechsle ich das gerade mit,
Schweden auf jeden Fall haben sie sich äh da zusammengesetzt mit so einer ähm Medienberatung und haben halt irgendwie alle zusammen äh getragen und haben halt irgendwie gemeinsam
darüber gesprochen, wie man in das ganze äh am besten rüberbringen könnte und das soll wohl ganz gute äh Ergebnisse gezeigt haben.
Wenn ich hier.
Den ganzen Wahnsinn ein bisschen unter den Griff zu halten. Könnte man auch mal in Deutschland machen.
Ja insbesondere da, ich weiß nicht wie viele Leute eigentlich noch fernsehen so also ich hab.
Man hört immer wieder davon.
Ja, ich habe das seit Jahren nicht mehr gemacht.
Ich auch nicht. Also es stimmt nicht ganz, ich es gibt.
Ich habe hier und da mal einen Fernseher eingeschaltet. Aber wenn ich halt Kindersendungen ähm.
Und Nachrichten und was könnte man noch gucken? Sport rausnehme, bleibt nicht sehr viel übrig.
Bei uns zu Hause gibt's gar keinen funktionierenden Fernseher, also der irgendwie äh ja Programmempfangen würde aus Kabel oder äh aus der Luft oder vom Satelliten.
Mhm.
Weil ja.
Für irgendwie alle paar Monate irgendwann mal äh ja war der Druck jetzt nicht so groß äh irgendwie nachdem ähm sie ADS.
B äh abgeschaltet hatten äh ja den Broadcast oder nicht abgeschaltet, sondern den auf HD umgestellt haben. So äh habe ich habe ich halt nicht mehr upgegradet.
So, für alle Leute, die äh noch Spaß haben ähm in dieser ganzen Korona Krise auch mal wieder was auszuehprobieren, sich noch weiter mit diesen ganzen Kram mental auch auseinanderzusetzen.
Habe ich noch ein äh lustiges Projekt entdeckt, das heißt the Micro Cover Projekt. Hast du davon schon gehört, Pavel.
Nur von dir jetzt äh also äh.
Ja, ich hab's, ja, ich habe jetzt auch noch nicht sehr viel Erfahrung damit äh gesammelt, aber ich dachte, ich erwähne es mal hier. Und zwar ist das sozusagen der Versuch, auch alle Daten zusammenzutragen, über was wie gefährlich ist.
Und daraus haben sie einen Cakeulater gebaut.
Wo man ähm verschiedene äh Dinge einstellen kann und ausrechnen kann, um dann eine quantifizierbare Größe dafür zu bekommen, wie gefährlich das jetzt ist.
Und die Einheit, denn sie Micro Cover wird.
Also sozusagen so Millionstelkowit. Ähm erinnert mich so ein bisschen an ähm die Einheit für äh so radioaktive äh Bestrahlung, so so.
Und sowas,
Genau, also Micro Covit ist sozusagen wie viele Micro Covers so oft ich hier herabstrahlen, wenn du irgendwas tust. Und dann gehst du halt in diesen Caterator rein und sagst halt erstmal, wo du bist, so, ne? Okay,
sage ich jetzt hier Germany, dann kannst du sagen, okay, ich bin in äh Berlin, kriege dann sofort angezeigt, wie viel Cases äh letzte Woche hier waren.
Auf wie viel Leute sich das äh äh verteilt in dem jeweiligen Bereich, also in dem Fall knapp dreieinhalb Millionen äh Einwohner,
und äh Testrate wird hier äh gleich mit reingegeben. Also sie tragen da wirklich einiges zusammen und äh liefern auch gleich so Zahlen für Privalenz et cetera. Das basiert natürlich jetzt alles auf diesen
Johns Hopkins Daten
und auch World Indata, also die tragen auch noch verschiedenste Quellen zusammen. So und wenn du gesagt hast, wo du bist, dann sagst du halt irgendwie auf welche Art und Weise du jetzt wo irgendwie bist, sagen wir mal
Rossry Store for Sixty Minutes, du gehst also einkaufen in Supermarkt.
Ne? Ähm und dann äh kann ich noch eintragen, wie viele Leute sind.
Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen schwierig, äh wie man das jetzt so genau sagt. Also man kann's unten auch noch äh genauer bestimmen.
Also äh Nirmi ist sozusagen.
Ja, wie viele Leute um mich herum sind, mit wie vielen ich da gerade reingehen, sage ich halt einfach mal, irgendwie eine.
Eine Person, die irgendwie im Durchschnitt in meiner Area ist und dann kann ich nochmal ein Activity.
Für.
Eine One-Time-Interaction, Haushaltsmitglied oder Partner angeben, ist alles äh extrem.
Naja, mhm.
Wird am Ende was ausgerechnet und also in Berlin gerade in Supermarkt gehen für eine Stunde äh hat vier Mikrokowitz. Was immer mir das jetzt sagt, aber es wäre eine Low-Riskactivity, sagen sie doch dazu.
Mhm.
Ja, ich meine die ganzen Werte, ja, es gibt da einige Presets und man kann auch äh also noch äh sone Person sind vierzig Mikrokowitz in Berlin.
Genau.
Ähm ja Eating Inrestrone Indoors zweitausend Mikrowith.
Restaurant Outdoors neunzig Mikrokowit.
Also und ein voller Kovit, also wenn man die Millionen voll hat, dann heißt es jetzt sozusagen die Chance.
Äh warte mal, ist einer, nee warte mal. Was ist ein.
Zweihundert Indimilien ist das, also sollte ich sagen, ich krieg's grad nicht ganz zusammen. Auf jeden Fall, man kriegt's ausgerechnet, wie groß die äh Chance in Prozent ist, dass man jetzt irgendwie sich infiziert. Können wir mal ein bisschen dran rumspielen.
Weiß ich hier, alle haben keine Maske auf und so weiter, dann gehen die Werte schnell äh nach oben. Laut Talking.
Da bist du schon mit zwanzigtausend, zwanzigtausend Mikrokovics dabei, wenn du die ganze Zeit noch rumschreist im Supermarkt, dann äh und keine Masken trägst.
Dann ist es schon Dangeresley Hai. Ja das vielleicht zum äh Rumspielen für euch vielleicht äh könnt ihr da interessante Erkenntnisse draus ziehen oder euch sonst irgendwie nur ein bisschen Zeit äh lostreten.
Ja und wir würde ich sagen.
Ja, wir sind.
Dann erstmal wieder zusammen, ne? Und gucken mal, was sich so äh passiert. Ich habe so das Gefühl, wir werden so in der nächsten Zeit wieder ein bisschen mehr zu betrachten haben.
Ja. Also bislang war's halt.
Noch immer so also außer jetzt bei dem ersten großen Ausbruch, aber immer wenn seitdem die Zahlen so angezogen haben äh,
gab's dann doch immer wieder entweder Plateaus oder äh dann doch Zeiten, äh wo es dann plötzlich wieder zurückgeht oder äh sich ändert das Ganze,
im Moment ist es
auch so, wie gesagt, die letzte Woche war eher so eine so ein bisschen fast Plateau Woche, aber jetzt die letzten Tage dann doch wieder äh angezogen. Also
ja es ist die Situation ist instabil und äh tendenziell ja gehen die gehen die Zahlen äh
äh ungehindert nach oben.
Also tut was dafür, dass sie gehindert werden. Bitte. Das wäre ganz gut
und wenn er euch nur mindestens um euch selber kümmert, damit's ja auch schon mal ein ein Anfang äh gemacht. Dann würde ich sagen, wir verbleiben mit äh offenen Versprechen, wenn wir wieder weiter äh machen, die nächste Sendung aufnehmen.
Machen das, wenn wir das Gefühl haben, es gibt wieder genug zu berichten. Ja und bis dahin.
Tschüss.